in September 2015 the world learned
German automaker Volkswagen had
installed illegal software in 11 million
cars it was designed to conceal excess
emissions during testing the Zil the
diesel cars were sold worldwide between
2008 and 2015
six Volkswagen employees were charged in
the United States over the scandal
Volkswagen settled with American
regulators and car owners for about
twenty billion dollars but his problems
may not be over German prosecutors last
week said that Volkswagen CEO Mateus
Muller is under investigation they are
looking at whether he kept investors in
the dark about the emissions scandal
Porsche a subsidiary of Volkswagen deny
the allegations the new york times
european economics correspondent Jack
Ewing covered this entire story he gives
a behind-the-scenes look in a new book
called faster higher farther the
Volkswagen scandal we reached out to VW
for comment about the book but have not
yet heard back Jack good morning good
morning
first of all incredible reporting
congratulations on what you've done here
you start the book with a story of a
group of West Virginia University
researchers what are they doing
exclaimed yeah well they had a grant
just to test some cars in the United
States diesel cars sold by Volkswagen
and BMW the idea was just to see whether
these cars could meet u.s. standards and
so they took them out on the road which
was not something that had been done
before and very quickly noticed some
very funny results the emissions were
way higher on the road than they were
when the same cars were tested in the
lab these were nitrogen oxide levels yet
nitrogen oxide levels which is a very
harmful gas that's why you got to
mention Dan Carter who made the time 100
influential list because without Dan
Carter you wouldn't have a book and we
wouldn't really know about this scandal
that's right Dan Carter was a guy who
managed the team at West Virginia
University oversaw the research and he
was the one that really got the ball
rolling that that uncovered the scandal
it was it they did they installed
illegal software
yeah the software could recognize when
the car was on rollers in a garage being
tested and when that was the case then
it cranked up the pollution controls so
that it would pass the test and the rest
of the time the cars polluted more than
a long-haul diesel truck an executive
apparently knew this was happening well
certainly up to a certain level they
knew it was happening they were involved
and what we don't know is how much
further it went up you mentioned that
the there's now an investigation against
us and what is this done to Volkswagen
both in terms of the compensation has
had to pay out as well as reputation it
certainly hurt the reputation they're
still trying to get their sales back in
the United States sales and the rest of
the world are kind of flat they haven't
collapsed I think the biggest problem
for Volkswagen is the cost is taking
away money that they need to be spending
on new technologies because there's a
big shift coming in the auto market but
at the end of the day Dan I mean Jack
Dan is the other guy at the end of the
day why did they do it because it they
didn't make a lot of money for it and
the people that were involved in so it
didn't make the company money and the
people involved they didn't make money
they were desperate to get back market
share in the United States and the way
they thought they would do that was by
selling diesels as an environmentally
friendly technology but the engineers
realized that they couldn't make the
cars compliant with the u.s. rules and
so they came up with his cheap I think
they probably meant it as a short-term
stopgap but then it became a habit funny
I lived in Germany for two years growing
up so my parents always liked diesel
cars we had VW diesel cars growing up
forever because the diesel gas was
cheaper for a period of time and they
thought it was green I mean they bought
kind of that message but you point out
that an MIT study found that from 2008
to 2015 will lead to 1,200 premature
deaths in Europe yeah well actually I
think the figure may even be higher
there was a study out last week by the
International Council on clean
transportation and they put the number
at 38,000 worldwide from excess diesel
nitrogen oxide emissions that's above
what's actually allowed by law how is
this behavior different from other
scandals like this I think that the
biggest thing is that the money wasn't
the motivation if you look at the
banking scandals it was usually people
who were trying to get big bonuses to
make money and this was just about
trying to defend market share and I
think meet the expectations that top
management had set for the employees
that the people who did this were really
just trying to hang on to their jobs no
you said go ahead no and how did you get
on to the store you may have said this
but well I I wasn't the guy who wrote
the story that was the EPA was the one
who put out a
Notice of Violation you just read this
story and seemed interesting right but
then you know I started pursuing it and
with other New York Times colleagues and
was able to talk to some of the people
involved so but you really described it
really well all corporate scandals stem
at least in part from unrealistic
targets coupled with dranconian
consequences for employees who failed to
deliver yeah and you see the same thing
at the environment Yeah right
Enron more recently Wells Fargo I think
they all have that element in common
right Jack Ewing thank you thank you for
having elections